sommes devant un auto portrait réalisé
par un artiste qui s'appelle julien
blais qui a été fait en 1883 comme lundi
que la date en bas à droite julien d est
un créole
il est né à l'arrêt une famille de
commerçants et ils quittent la réunion
dans les années 1870 pour aller se
former en fait à l'école des beaux-arts
à paris c'est un des rares un des rares
artistes n'aient à la réunion qui n'est
pas tiqué gars peut-être une côte et
autodidacte au début mais qui est allé
se former auprès de m auprès de
professeurs en métropole et parmi la
toute petite production qui nous restent
parce que c'est un artiste qui est mort
relativement jeune et les morts à 40 ans
on a quelques portraits en inde et est
ce qu'ils sont des petits tableaux et
surtout le musée léon dierx a eu de la
chance de 2,2 d'avoir en donation en
fait son auto portrait c'est à dire le
portrait de l'artiste lui même alors
c'est un portrait qui s'inscrit dans une
longue tradition d'autoportraits
d'artistes les artistes en faisant un
auto portrait c'était un moyen pour eux
des pratiques et d'exercer le portrait
est quelque chose qui leur permet de
gagner leur vie parce que quand on
commande un portrait ca moyen pour les
artistes de gagner de l'argent
donc comment faire un portrait il faut
s'exercer il faut pratiquer comment
peut-on pratiquer en faisant son auto
portrait pour pouvoir justement exercer
sa peinture
les cadrages la couleur la luminosité
etc
et là il fait son auto portrait donc il
faut imaginer une toile de ce côté ci
est en face de lui un miroir dans lequel
ils se regardent et ensuite ils posent
au fur et à mesure les compos les
couleurs sur sa toile
donc du coup ça donne ce regarderai
persan très vif il nous interpelle quand
ils nous regardent
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce portrait il n'a pas cherché
à se représenter comme un artiste ayant
réussi on sent que c'est un jeune
artiste qui est débutant
mais il aurait pu me dire voilà je
décide de me représenter avec un livre
avec une statue montrant ce qu'est ce
qui est plus important pour moi c'est je
suis artiste mais c'est l'idée c'est mes
réflexions c'est mes lectures et cernon
il a décidé de se représenter comme un
praticien comme un artisan il à sa
palette à la main il à ses pinceaux son
vêtement est un peu usé il est agile
assis sur une chaise assez modeste il a
un chapeau sur sa tête pour se protéger
on peut imaginer qu'il fait froid dans
son atelier et qu'il est en train de
peindre dans quelque chose qui a un peu
à un peu sommaire bref il il décide de
se montrer vraiment en artisan de la
peinture et non pas comme on aurait pu
le faire en quelques uns qui privilégie
plutôt le côté intérêts qu'il a il prit
j'y connais vraiment le côté manuel de
la peinture c'est au portrait est assez
rare on en a très peu dans les
collections mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que il a été à
l'élève de le man qui était lui-même un
élève d'ingres et on retrouve ici toute
la grande tradition du portrait
classique de la peinture du dessin
parfait issue justement de l'information
d'un des plus grands artistes du 19e
siècle français en l'occurrence jean
dominique